okay so yesterday I was on the Jesse Lee
Peterson program which is I believe a
syndicated radio show and it's now on
Newsmax TV which is like extreme
right-wing TV and they've been asking me
to come back on the program for a while
now and the first time I did it it was
such a waste of time because the guy
it's just a disastrous program I can't
imagine why anyone would watch this
program nor even hire this guy to host
the show I don't really know the
logistics of the arrangement but I
agreed to go back on and you know I'll
be honest I didn't take it seriously
because the first time I was on it
wasn't a serious interview it was just
basically talking points that this guy
would stayed and whenever I would try to
actually have a conversation about the
facts he would just go on to the next
question so I wasn't taking it seriously
but he kicked me off I got kicked off of
the show I think it was scheduled to be
like a roughly 20 minute interview and I
think after about seven minutes I get
kicked off and I was just going to play
for you the part of the interview that
I'm on but then after he starts going
into this unintelligible explanation of
how he didn't remember that he had ever
had me on even though then he talks
about how I did the same thing this time
as I did last time but I thought you
didn't remember that I was on last time
it's so weird and then the best part for
me Pat is he starts talking to his
producer yeah and you can tell that his
producer clearly seems to be more and
more or less in line with Jesse Lee
Peterson's politics but his producer
gets that I was actually trying to have
a conversation about well Jesse defend
what you're saying about Donald Trump
and the producer and Jesse Lee Peterson
seemed to get into a disagreement about
me do you think this was your big break
and you ruined it I think that this was
an absolute disaster for the future of
my career on television stations like
Newsmax because I assume that I'm now
blacklisted because they just cut me off
because I wasn't communicating the way
that they wanted me to communicate I
loved the terms that Jesse uses like
people on the left are children of the
lie end of the line Donald Trump is the
great white hope great white hope
children of the lie I'm part of the
group of Satan and evil people anyway I
got kicked off of right-wing TV that's
our interview today let's take a listen
to it the future of the Democratic Party
is not looking good not looking good at
all and that is good for America it is
not a negative
it is a positive I have with me David
Pakman he is a progressive host an
executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program the
David Pakman show
and I wanted to talk to David about the
Democratic Party political correctness
and president Trump's performance this a
year now since has been elected and a
great white hope is making America great
again David welcome back to the show oh
I can't even tell you what a pleasure it
is to be back with you today thank you
yeah you walk a man I I want to talk to
you about the great white hope first the
president how would you rate him you
know he's been elected a year now and
how would you rate the president on a
scale of one to ten ten being best I
would say probably a zero really and why
is that well I buy his own campaign
promises he was going to build a wall
with Mexico that they would pay for
that's not happening it's not going to
happen he was going to repeal and
replace Obamacare with something better
three proposals to replace it all would
have led to 15 to 23 million people
ending up without care but all of those
failed to pass another big campaign
promise he said he would do it right
away
failed to do it he said he was going to
renegotiate trade deal still hasn't done
that he also said he was going to pass a
tax cut bill not looking good the Senate
now and a whole bunch of trouble trying
to figure out well how do we do this
it's going to explode the deficit and
we're not going to be able to go back to
our constituents and explain to them why
did we vote to explode the deficit so I
mean I think by his own standards he's
accomplished none of the things he
promised to accomplish well he hasn't
been there a year yet he was elected a
year ago today do us bet or did us bet
all those things to happen within the
first year did he I mean he's the one
who said he's the one who said he didn't
say he would do all those things in the
first year are you asking me whether I
believe Donald Trump's campaign promises
is that the question I'm asking you did
you believe that the president the great
white hope would do all those things in
the first
year of being in office I didn't believe
him when he said he would repeal
Obamacare right away no I didn't believe
him how about the rest of the things
that you mentioned did you think he
would do all those things in the first
year of being in office no but he hasn't
done any of them amazing
hold on Jessie wait a second what's Amit
what was it you tell me what he's done
how would you rate well we have a
conservative Supreme Court justice on
the US Supreme Court right now we have
the job so coming back what job do you
talk to me about the jobs just you how
has it changed
come down into Obama give me the numbers
we've got a record ninety-five point
three million people out of the work
maybe you must come down the the filing
of unemployment have gone down the
illegal illegal aliens coming across the
borders illegally ins coming across the
borders are down he has managed to put a
hold on radical Islamic terrorists where
they are coming into our country it's a
lot like I don't want to trap I know
blocked and it's not true as president
Trump done those talking points me
nothing the travel ban has been blocked
three times I know that you don't like
demand nothing he's gonna be aiming to
do will make you happy so that's what I
want putting words in my mouth you know
that's not fair what he could you really
honest here Jesse you know that calm
down David for over 60 years the
Democratic Party has gotten worse
destroying the family masculinity they
hate men real men straight men they just
they hate the unborn child so they're
still pushing abortion they have no love
or respect for blacks and Hispanics they
believe that the blacks and Hispanics
are only worth it's more vote they are
attacking Christianity and
straight mail you are a progressive what
does it mean to be a progressive what is
that it's for progress and against
stagnation and a return to values that
are outdated and irrelevant in modern
society and what type of progress give
an example of progress ah the reduction
in incredibly damaging economic
inequality the push for a basic level of
health care for everybody regardless of
ability to pay a push for an economy
that is not going to allow the richest
to become endlessly richer while the
poor continue to be poor I mean there's
a long list I mean I think you know the
problem is that there's a lot I'm not a
Democrat by the way I've never been a
Democrat so if the idea is progressive
so I'm asking about that so let me ask -
I didn't even finish answering the
question how long do we have because
this is a very weird interview we didn't
even you I was trying to get you to tell
me exactly what Trump had done to
achieve those so-called achievements and
you moved on to the Democratic Party
it's a very strange interview I've never
experienced anything like it well that's
the first time in life for everything
let me ask the military paid for
so-called sex reassignment surgery and
our tax dollars are paying for even
though we don't agree with that at all
is living who the conservative Christian
people of this country
is that as that progress when men are
confused about their gender and women
are confused about theirs and now we're
paying for is that progress are you a
fiscal conservative Jessie answer that
question David in that progress well are
you a fiscal conservative David answer
that question are you is that progress
it's not an example of something that is
or isn't progress but the reason I'm
asking whether you're a fiscal
conservative is called it's cheaper it's
cheaper okay for those procedures why
don't you discharge to find and
discharge every transgender member of
the military so if you're a fiscal
conservative never heard you say that
you are you should favor the cheaper we
have those procedures and not paying for
it would cost to find and discharge all
these chapters David remember David
you're not here to communicate I really
appreciate you coming I'm gonna let you
go it's a waste of time to talk to you
we're not communicating you acted like
that because you're asking bizarre
questions you're an idiot and you wait
to my time appreciate and Mon Ami all
right there's no comment see you bye
goodbye let him go that's a progressive
folks all men who are progressive of
males who are progressive or weak people
they are weak people and what have these
people aren't it doesn't even make sense
they don't come to communicate because
they're too insecure and David Pakman is
a very insecure progressive real men are
not progressive I'm progressive whatever
they are that's not the nature of a man
I don't even know why you guys invited a
guy back amazing stuff this is what has
happened to the men of America today not
all that old at all but many of them
have become girly men girly men
it just it's ridiculous it's not
progressive when the military is paying
for a confused male or female and we
don't know yet was it a man who was put
on a woman's body part I wasn't a woman
who put on a man body parts and pretends
to be something that they're not the
military pay for their phones
can you believe that we are paying for
it the military are not it's not paying
for it we are paying for it so I just
want to make you you know out there that
we had David Pakman
before and I forgot that we would have
we had him on my producer reminder we
had reminded me that we had but I forgot
that God can't communicate he's a
deceiver
he is a part of the family of the
children of the lie so I never would
have had him back on it's a waste of
time
my producers here James why did you have
him back because he's a he's a as you
picked up on he's like a lively debate
er well we're not a debater
well I know but in the sense that he is
lively and very well known popular
respected in terms of being like a Yahoo
to children of the lie yeah oh respected
by Satan's Pope's correct okay
but I mean like he is a little different
from them in that he he seems to think a
little bit more for himself like he
doesn't he doesn't I know but he seems
to well how do you think he didn't do it
the first time he's on the show I didn't
do it just now how to you he seemed to
think mean differences he he definitely
is different from them he's evil